*COMMENTS EXPLODE ON SCREEN*
From the film maker behind the movie about the jazz guy
Who likes jazz SO much he ends up alone!
Comes a movie about a jazz guy who likes jazz SO much he ends up alone!
MAN!
What did jazz do to Damien Chazelle?
LA LA LAND
Witness one of the most Oscar-nominated films
of ALL time!
That will have future generations saying:
Musical about show buisness?
Well no wonder the academy left it up!
And this tale of passion
Love
and ditching all that nonsense when your career takes off!
As two ambitious people follow their Hollywood dreams
Until the romance almost gets in the way
PHEW!
Dodged that bullet!
You two almost had a compromise!
Journey to a fantasy version of Los Angeles
Where the landmarks are never crowded
No one takes their phones out before jumping in the pool
And gridlock is just a chance to free a jazz quartet from human traffickers
Don't start playing!
NOWS YOUR CHANCE!
RUN!
Meet Sebastian & Mia
She loves acting!
And wants to be an actress (duh)
He loves jazz and
wants to be a...
uh
Jazz-isist?
Watch as these two hotties pursue their goals with single-minded ambition
And complete disregard for anything that isn't them
whether its their neighbors
theater audiences
DOWN IN FRONT!
This buisness
the jobs that pay them to live
the 14 people on this email change she didn't BCC
or these guys trying to put on a concert
"It's brand new every night. Very, very exciting"
Then if you wanted to like jazz,
YOU SHOULDN'T TALK THE WHOLE TIME THEY ARE PLAYING!!!
God, your so lucky you look like Ryan Gosling!
Settle in for a film that *clears throat* borrows
from the great musicals from the past
that proves it's easier to teach a world-class singer how to act than two world-class actors how to sing
as Ryan and Emma's relationship radiates with effortless chemistry
and their dancing radiates with the general lack of effort
C'MON JAKE! THERE WERE SIMILAR OTHER HITS! THEY'RE RUSHING! THEY'RE DRAGGING!
THEY'RE..
doing whatever that is...
so sing along
for a beautiful looking film
that goes down sweeter than a cake made entirely out of frosting
featuring unforgettable songs like
The Los Angeles song
Guys, GUYS! Ugh, I'm sorry. No. There... There's been a huge mistake...I..
MOONLIGHT!
You guys are this week's honest trailer!
This is not a joke guys!
Moonlight, this is your honest trailer!
but...all we have left is another La La Land song!
are we seriously gonna do this? C; (yas)
uh.. uh oh... ok
Starring
Did I say it right? SCORE!
You know, it's frustrating that these two great movies will always be stuck together
Wait... we're not helping are we?